Game of Thrones Season 8 is the most anticipated
TV release of 2019, and HBO has been super
secretive about the production.
But it looks like some footage has leaked
from the new season, revealing surprising
twists in the future of Jon Snow, Cersei Arya,
and others.
In this leaked shot, it looks like Jon is
captured by Dothraki – just like Daenerys
was in Season 6.
Jon is then forced to fight as a gladiator
in what looks like Daznak’s Pit in Meereen.
It is surprising that Jon is here is in the
east instead of fighting white walkers in
Westeros.
But this arc seems important for Jon personally.
Cause there’s this dream sequence with Jon
and Ned Stark, the man who Jon thinks was
his father.
Jon tries to free Ned from chains while the
Mountain swings a sword around with a triangle
on his head.
The theme here is that Jon feels trapped in
his responsibilities, when his true passion
is to train and become the top ranked professional
tennis player in Westeros – as well as a
three time cover model for Men’s Health
magazine, like Khal Drogo before him.
So this is a surprising but inspiring conclusion
to Jon’s story.
In Season 7, Queen Cersei plans to hire a
mercenary army to help her win Westeros . And
in this leaked shot, she gets her army, and
Cersei personally leads them to battle.
But this might go badly for her, cause it
looks like Cersei’s wounded, and even loses
an eye.
Who does this to her?
Well, Arya Stark wants to kill Cersei, and
here we see Arya wearing crimson and gold
– maybe she uses her Faceless magic to infiltrate
the Lannisters, joins their army, and tries
to assassinate Cersei.
But Cersei won’t go down easy – she upgrades
her ballista to a minigun, and goes all Neo
on Stark asses.
Luckily, Hodor returns to stop her.
But Arya flees the war to take up a life of
crime with a strange old man.
Sansa gets fed up with being the only Stark
who doesn’t have a superpower – like,
Arya’s a shapeshifting ninja, Bran’s a
psychic, Jon can’t bloody die – so Sansa
decides to learn telekinesis, and the power
of flight.
We see her explode with fire and light, finally
confirming that Sansa is Azor Ahai, the prophesied
hero who’ll save Westeros.
This is a dramatic change in Sansa’s destiny.
But she remains loyal to her family.
Because her new tattoo is of a direwolf – representing
her love for House Stark.
Last season, Daenerys embraced her power as
a Targaryen queen.
But she still seems torn in her identity.
Here she wears white fur with a red scarf
tight round her neck.
The scarf represents Dany’s role as a Targaryen
queen, while the white fur refers to the white
lions-coat Dany wears in the books in her
role as khaleesi.
So Dany feels torn between her past and her
future.
Her solution is a rejection of both.
Instead of using mighty Targaryen dragons
as her weapons, Dany decides to just shoot
cunts.
Guns are way easier to manage than dragons,
and this saves HBO money on expensive CGI.
So expect fewer dragons in Season 8.
Last time we saw Jaime, he left Cersei and
rode north.
But it looks like his breakup with his lifelong
lover really hurts Jaime emotionally.
He ends up changing his look with a handlebar
moustache and some highly symbolic tattoos.
The name Katherine may refer to Catelyn, who
Jaime swore an oath to in Season 1.
This image of a beheading may refer to Ned
Stark, who Jaime attacked before Ned’s death.
And this cross may refer to the inn at the
crossroads where Catelyn captured Tyrion,
and sparked the Lannister-Stark war.
So these tattoos are a tapestry of Jaime’s
feelings of guilt to the Starks, but it also
refers to his own family.
This spiderweb design refers to Jaime great-grandmother
Rohanne of House Webber – look it up nerds.
So Jaime’s tattoos represent the conflicts
that will define him and his moustache in
the season to come.
In Season 7, Tyrion tried to help his queen
through strategic advice – all of which
failed disastrously.
So it looks like next season, Tyrion tries
to use other skills, like his combat prowess
and business acumen.
But ultimately, Tyrion does a Radagast and
retires to the woods to become a bearded hermit.
Maybe he wasn’t cut out for the game of
thrones after all.
Karl “Fookin” Tanner and Ellaria Sand
seemed dead, but it now looks like they’re
alive, running a promising tech startup in
Cardiff.
Gilly decides to break up with Sam, and moves
to Bristol to shack up with Gendry.
Sam is so heartbroken that he joins the Faith.
Hot Pie started the series as an amoral bully,
before growing into a slightly more noble
character.
But sadly, the leaks show Hot Pie returning
to petty bullying – stealing an ice cream
cone from a small child.
It turns out that Margaery survived Cersei’s
wildfire last season with only her hair burned
off.
She gets a Tyrell tattoo to commemorate her
dead family.
The Hound suffers a tragic head injury.
Bronn finally gets the retirement he always
wanted.
And Tywin suffers in his own personal hell
for his crimes against Westeros.
So this looks to be a bold Season 8.
We’re getting surprising twists in major
storylines, and some fresh new character makeovers.
But it’s a shame that all this footage was
leaked.
You’d think that by now, HBO would fix their
online security –Thrones Season 5 was hacked
in 2015 , then again in 2017 . HBO must be
using insecure passwords or something.
They should get a password manager like Dashlane.
Dashlane automatically generates and remembers
secure passwords for all your sites.
It even has a breach alert feature, so if
you get hacked, you’ll be notified before
all your episodes leak.
So Dashlane’s security is great for TV networks
– but it’s also important for YouTubers,
businesses, and anyone who wants their logins
and transactions safe.
The app is secure, easy to use, and free – so
sign up to Dashlane at the link below.
This helps support Alt Shift X and helps you
stay secure.
You can also upgrade to a premium membership
which syncs across devices, using our offer
code to get 10% off.
So don’t be like HBO – secure your data
with our sponsor Dashlane.
Thank you for watching, and thanks to the
Patrons, including Keiasha Solomon, Ashley
Watts, Johari Ismail, and Lola Pli.
Cheers.